i anda nada lá muito votada
é uma honra estar na vossa presença e
sete módulos e eu pretendo introduzimos
uma técnica que é tão antiga uma própria
humanidade é renovada é e eu defendo que
mais que teorizar sobre uma técnica que
nesse caso fry próximo e eu defendo que
devemos passar pela experiência entra na
minha coleção eu propus quando me
convidaram não só eu vou estar um pouco
sobre nós mas também é proporcionar uma
experiência aos presente eo valor é
vocês ao mundo maravilhoso da hipnose
portanto o meu desafio é que é pertinho
seguintes segurança na cadeira porque
vamos fazer uma viagem maravilhosa vamos
nessa
ok para a mãe quando falamos da hipnose
o chavão hipnose desperta nas pessoas
alguma confusão alguns mitos talvez
alguns aiué é todavia se nós pensarmos
que nós entramos no estado
psicologicamente dentro da hipnose é
cada 90 minutos
se pensarmos que nós é uma técnica de
grande abrangência clínica é em suma
todos pensarmos que a hipnose é
puramente comunicação europeus que irão
concordar comigo que devemos pelo menos
tentar conhecer e esse mecanismo essa é
maravilhosa abordagem que permita
compreender a máquina mais complexa do
universo
ela está na vossa cabeça está na minha
cabeça está na nossa cabeça que é o
cérebro humano
de facto eu entendo que a natureza do
tônus com o maravilhoso computador
biológico e do fato ela é capaz de quase
tudo
infelizmente o cérebro humano não traz
nenhum manual de instruções e outra uma
vez
ele creio que nós será um dos manuais em
substituições que nós procurávamos para
fazer uso e utilizar esta enorme
potencial adormecido que é nossa meta
com o podemos definir a hipnose de facto
dependendo do modelo teórico que aborda
o a técnica nós podemos definir a
hipnose como um estado específico de
consciência em comparação com estados
normais de vigília e e do sono é tendo
em conta que a nossa atenção é flutuante
é quando entramos não sabe de que nós
não estamos
entramos num no estado do foco em nossa
mente se vira mais por nossa interior em
detrimento da consciência periférica é
normal é fácil entrar em transe
hipnótico não obstante os medos seus
medos
os tabus e os seios eu é que sou
psicoterapeuta pessoa responsável uma o
corpo clínico de uma clínica é aqui no
porto aveiro lisboa e existem muitos
mitos
relativamente à equipe nós é um dos
medos hipótese é muito comum e podemos
até considerar é que o mais é continuar
mais tempo a explicar é um mito não
acordar quando alguém chega ao
consultório e desmaiou do gênero ó
doutor fraco vai anunciar eu nunca mais
acordou e eu tenho que explicar a pessoa
mas em hipnose é sono você não vai
dormir mas ela insiste em dar alguma
coisa tem uma síncope cardíaca e eu
fiquei atrás e nunca mais acordar e
ouvir um passo e disse você vai pagar 80
euros de consulta para dormir e que nós
não é sono não faz sentido porque os
padrões elétrons pelo gráficos são
diametralmente oposta ao sono
outro mito relativamente à hipnose é que
nós podemos controlar a mente do sujeito
hipnotizado podemos fazê lo voar coisas
que eu não quero e é o qormi uma pessoa
que não tens algo do gênero fraco vai
saber a minha conta no banco fazendo
assinar um cheque criando todo o
dinheiro
não é possível fazer isso frustra sempre
o controlo jamais perde o controlo do
processo porque é importante que
entendam que quando estudos apontam que
a nossa meta nossa arquitetura neuronal
está concebida para entrarem estados
biológicos e naturais trânsito
eu penso que é fácil compreender que é
desde que nós fomos concebidos com
arquitetura ronaldo sabe foi consumida
nós entramos em trânsito de forma
natural e biológica e quando é que isso
acontece
nós entramos em trânsito por exemplo
quando tínhamos acordados
nós entramos em transe hipnótico quando
entrarmos em plenário
quando vamos a conduzir para o emprego
para a faculdade e não damos conta do
tempo passar
nós entramos em transe quando estamos
apaixonados
quando vemos provisão quando estamos na
internet
a televisão é altamente hipnótica
os smartphones são altamente hipnóticos
já pararam que quando nós estamos a ver
um filme
esquecemos do ruído da rua esquecemos
dos miúdos a brincar na cozinha porque o
nosso foco neste momento é o enredo do
filme e se acontece uma cena de alta
tensão
nós sentimos os efeitos de uma descarga
de adrenalina na corrente sanguínea
porque é que só acontece sabendo que
aquilo é uma história falsa que são
atores que estão a fazer
estamos realmente num estado alterado de
consciência ou seja estamos em auto
hipnose
quando eu digo que a hipnose é tão na
própria os grad também é importante que
se diga que para nós é puramente
comunicação
eu vi hoje é que que desde que nós temos
nós buscamos a informação
certo é importante considera que é
impossível não comunicarmos nós
comunicamos de forma analógica e digital
e um dos piores da comunicação humana
diz que mesmo que tínhamos em silêncio
mesmo que escolhemos igualmente para o
alto de um monte de uma montanha
nós estamos a comunicar estamos a
comunicar que queremos estar sozinhos
certo mas mais importante que comunicará
é saber comunicar para alberto meia
william
um psicólogo da ufla que fez um estudo
em 71 demonstrou que só cerca de 7% do
conteúdo da mensagem é verbal 38% é
intensidade a forma as pausas inflexão
voz que eventualmente transmitir
mensagens mais 55 por cento da mensagem
pela nossa comunicação é corporal é
linguagem não verbal gest o silêncio a
forma como os últimos a forma como
olhamos a pessoa que estamos a contactar
e isso é fundamental para conseguirmos
de facto comunicar em é quando nós
trabalhamos com a hipnose
quando nós eventualmente tentar nos
comunicar é fazemos uso desses
mecanismos de comunicação para criar um
estado natural
o estado em que certa forma pessoa está
habituada
só que passa por elas em e atos tempo
curtos
o mico na outra ponta um especialista em
hipnose procura manter esse ato tempo
esse status especial da atenção para
fazer mudanças qualitativas e
quantitativas já que eu entendo que a
equipe nova é mais ou menos uma uma
forma de sonhar acordados é em que vai
permitir que as nossas crenças nós
queremos mentais
as nossas verdades as lutas sejam mais
flexíveis e precisamos fazer as mudanças
que às vezes nós precisamos para
encontrarmos mais serenos para
encontrarmos mais mas essa vírus e até
para sentirmos que efetivamente nós
temos a vida nas nossas mãos
quem me conhece sabe que eu faço entre
nós há mais de 20 anos foi privatizada
há cerca de 20 anos atrás
e parafraseando fernando pessoa que diz
é primeiro estranha-se e depois
entranhas
foi paixão à primeira vista e eu percebi
que a hipnose em momento algum previa o
control
eu percebi que em nós em momento algum
me controlar a mente o seguinte
simplesmente quem inova estava tudo
aumenta o controle das minhas faculdades
minhas são virados estava tenha
capacidade deles do baixo sabor tório
experiências e saberes acumulados no
alinhamento e fazer uso de deus pra
tivesse potenciar a imensa que fui dados
quer seja em termos memória quer seja em
termos de actividade quer seja é em
termos de criatividade numa tarefa ou
numa profissão
de facto é minha paixão clipe nosso vou
me expor a hipnose ao longo do tempo e
uma coisa eu percebi é que infelizmente
hipnose é prática de todas as
civilizações desde os antigos egípcios
aos gregos mas a tanzânia é ter quadros
mais temos que ficar as civilizações
trivice dos ritos de curandeirismo o
digamos chamar era o hipnólogo astral
mas quanto mais procurava
quanto mais buscava a origem da hipnose
e eu percebi que a hipnose pets nas
brumas dos tempos
nós recebemos o dom da vida a 100 mil
milhões de anos e desde essa altura os
nossos anos procuram buscam informação
realmente procuram passar comunicação
para que os vindouros possam se adaptar
e sobreviver melhor de toda forma a
forma de comunicar é nada mais nada
menos a estratégia que visa adotou para
evoluir porque desde a primeira célula
próxima área tem capacidade de explorar
uma e dividir sua natureza percebeu que
era relevante adquirir informação para
melhor se adaptar para que a vida
pudesse sobreviver adaptar se inclui ou
seja o nosso a vida evoluiu ao longo de
milhões de anos eo nosso cérebro facto
foi adquirindo cada vez maior capacidade
e essa coisa extraordinária que é o
nosso cérebro que foi concebido para
comunicar foi cancelado para adquirir
informação é desenvolver o tática
em mecanismos cada vez mais
surpreendentes para comunicar e dar um
significado o meio que o rodeava
todavia apesar dos nossos sábios
altamente ruídos é ter desenvolvido
extraordinário e mental longo de milhões
de anos algumas partes do nosso cérebro
que não são de facto por feitas por
exemplo é a algumas ilusões de ótica
pode ser consideradas insanas
por exemplo esta é chamada a ilusão do
pouso ou também conhecida como usando a
linha do comboio
dá nos a sensação que temos objetos de
dimensões diferentes que na realidade
são da mesma dimensão seu neste momento
perguntar se a vocês e aqui estamos na
teoria das formas da gestalt sã o
quadrado cima é igual ou abaixo
obviamente que a resposta é que não se
mantemos um quadro cinzento na parte de
baixo temos um cravo branco
no entanto a ilusão é uma resposta
errada
na realidade os cuidados são ter mesma
cor
isso acontece e não fiquem zangados com
os elos porque as forças diariamente
para dar digamos um ambiente estava num
sentido continuidade previdência boa
forma como bicho pega se tal teoria da
forma que nós utiliza digamos esses bugs
essas essas falhas do cérebro humano
para eventualmente convive com o estado
digamos de ilusão que primeiro o fato é
ceder o manancial de informações do
curso sobre um sítio
fruto das nossas experiências fruto dos
novos saberes que vem e não só da nossa
infância nessa mãe dele diria caro e um
vem de gerações atrás e talvez com uma
espécie de memória genética possa estar
acumulado no nosso interior possui da
hipnose há três grandes que os poços que
é importante para percebermos um
mecanismo no funcionamento da hipnose o
primeiro posto é que o cérebro só opera
no prudente o passado presente e futuro
é uma função da nossa mente
gente a nossa mente inconsciente vivo
apresenta opera no presente
o fundo proposto é que o real é igual ao
imaginar no nosso cérebro estar dentro
de uma caixa negra não é essa diferença
que eu tenho no exterior até o exterior
os novos menus sensoriais leva uma
informação que eu dar uma imagem uma
realidade mas efetivamente o nosso
cérebro é cego surdo e mudo
se nós soubéssemos estimular
determinadas áreas do cérebro para a cor
essas áreas
iam criar - a honda cor nossa mesmo que
não existisse essa cor
por último outros posto é com nossos
egos forças por todos e não imaginamos e
se nós formos capaz efetivamente do
focar lugar o foco da nossa mente em ao
realizarmos o alto dissemos nós a bahia
já mil e uma maneiras de concretizar
evento aumenta o que nós idealizamos
ocorre agora aquela frase famosa frase
do alto disney quando ela diz é não se
preocupe com a distância entre os sonhos
e realidade se vocês possam ganhar os
também pode realizá los efetivamente nós
permite aceder é esse enorme potencial
do brasileiro é que nós permite
efectivamente fazer uso dos recursos
experiências e saberes acumulados e aí
nós permite sobretudo compreender um
pouco esta magnífica estrutura esse
magnífico computador biológico que
eventualmente a natureza nos conseguiu e
que a maioria das vezes nós é puro
preconceito ou desconhecimento por
dúvida é não sabemos usar indevidamente
em nosso benefício
e eu prometi no início da minha
profissão que é mais do que utilizará
sobre nossa eu gostaria de demonstrar
alguns fenômenos de hipnose com os
presentes
no entanto é
gostaria de terminar esta pata teórica
da minha apresentação sem é citar uma
frase do charles chaplin que pra mim é
traduzir um pouquinho é o magnífico é
instrumento que a natureza dotou que é o
nosso cérebro é ea frase é mais ou menos
essa o ser humano é o mais incrível
o mecanismo já criado nela encontramos
todos os credos inclusive da nossa
sociedade é baseado neste grande
proposto é baseado nesta grande homem de
certa forma nos ensinou a viver que eu
gostaria neste momento estou a olhar
para o tempo que importava investimento
deve estar a pensar mas não tenha ido
com o tempo é imaginado que uma
construção da mente pois é nós estamos
todos a construir esse tempo então eu
torna real já com cérebro não distingo
real do imaginário
então eu o tempo resta gostaria fazer
uma experiência bem interessante como os
presentes para que vocês possam
implementar é e não posso local nossas
cadeiras o que é passar por um estado de
hipnose
ok eu costumo dizer que eu e pode
comprimir um carinho que vocês estão
demasiado sérios
eu costumo dizer que o transe hipnótico
é mais ou menos como o sexo
o curso é a primeira vez depois não
querem outra coisa tá bom então vamos lá
vamos fazer uma experiência muito bem e
eu disse durante a minha coleção que
entramos em status biológicos e naturais
trans é cada 90 minutos e também diz que
cada um de nós a preenchimento tem uma
arquitetura jornal que foi
filogeneticamente consumida pintar em
estados biológicos e naturais trans e
pretendo provar isso então vamos lá
uma esperança muito simples é importante
fechar os olhos e tomar chá todos os
olhos por favor gostaria que neste
momento simplesmente fizeram isso assim
se imagina são muito simples
imaginem que neste momento tem diante de
vocês
a vossa sobremesa predileta para alguns
a uma determinada peça de fruta para
outros são um dom especial
talvez aqui o vôo da avó
as 11 uma sobremesa que vocês adoram
agora imaginem o prato dentre vós
procurem ver dimensão a textura ea cor e
agora vou explodir algo muito simples de
higiene que pega num trailer e corta um
pedaço dessa surpresa sim então por
favor agora o sabor a textura o cheiro e
gosto não tentem degustar essa deliciosa
sobremesa na boca ao mesmo tempo tenta
encurtar a última vez em que sentiram e
sabor na nossa obra e talvez neste
momento vocês possam experimentar a
explosão de sabores que está a chegar a
voz e se quiserem incluir agora faça num
além dos olhos nos olhos abram os olhos
porque estamos a levar a maioria do
acesso
nós meus senhores é que nós é tão
simples como respirar e se você pode
inspirar você pode improvisar e podem
estar em transe certo seria fazer agora
era uma demonstração de alguns final não
se novos caiu catalepsia companhia é e
para isso precisava de alguns
voluntários todavia tem uma advertência
a fazer um dos postos da equipe nova é
que ninguém é economizado se não quiser
certo portanto se o objetivo é ver aqui
o palco para uma daquelas cadeiras e
provar que não conseguem da empresa
não perca tempo admite já não
conseguiram avisar que não queira ser
hipnotizado tanto é esse esforço
voluntário que é assim uma precisão três
vontade eu gostaria apenas que investe
num elemento interessado em passar com
uma criança maravilhosa em passar por
uma experiência que realmente jamais
esquecerá
e se vocês tiverem de fato realmente em
passar por essa experiência e vou fazer
forma gratuita como é óbvio que eu seria
entanto que essa aqui alguns cuidados
podem ver por três convidados
sim claro nota muito vai além
é eu sei que sou é assim que é
efectivamente é muito fácil entrar em
transe hipnótico
a última promessa não confia salina na
faculdade
franciné do são joão é vieram também um
grupo de alunos e um deles disse olhe eu
não vim aqui para desafiar mas eu não
acredito que sou capaz de você e eu
disse não tem como ser basta
simplesmente se enfrentaram estado atrás
então eu quero fazer um exercício muito
simples muito rápido com vocês que vão
permitir perceber que tipo de
resistência vocês fazem a hipnose pode
ser então o processo é muito simples eu
quero que vocês fizessem assim as mãos
exatamente e abram os tetos nós chamados
celeste mantenha nos abertos mais
possível o mais aberto possível
exatamente qual é o seu nome
carolina é o que você faz algo muito
simples possa imaginar
também aqui as mãos que você imagina que
eu tenho um elástico do craque e vou
começar a apertar o que eu acho que é
exatamente a mesma que eu acho que a pec
vai conhecer um final muito interessante
nos seus dentes que está a sentir nos
desapontar
e à medida que os reds vão apertando
naturalmente você pode sentir outras
coisas
neste momento estou perguntando que tipo
de sensações
você pode ter agora a medida com os
dedos vão apertando e quando você se
permite erros dessa petten permite que
surjam com certeza está em boas mãos com
a sentir que há momentos de fundo dessa
faixa a mais um pouquinho mais um
pouquinho e estatística
deixa eu ficar com certeza que está em
boas mãos e está a chegar a chegar a
chegar a chegar mais um pouquinho e quer
o sentimento que respira fundo e
carolina anapolina isso a população
precisa ver se consigo
qual é o nome lo na empresa há também
uma segunda original por uma voz ea ong
da madeira vai complementar a logomarca
que ele passou mal
ele passou mal olhe páginas nacional ao
ponto fixo nacional nas violentas ou não
nem desde quando passou na polônia
vai acontecer uma coisa muito certo o
foco da sua visão vai mudar
a suspensão vai mudar dona e quando vão
tocar no seu rosto
você pode ir a fundo o dólar calma e
profundamente sempre atenta a minha voz
não diga que vai anunciando coluna você
vai aprender com o brasil partindo o
enfrentamento do problema só aumenta a
velocidade que você precisa tentar
outras ainda mais profundo é martin do
martim
você vai conhecendo ainda não sendo um
'recall' mama é o fundamento gosta dela
nosso ataque e isso torna torna isso
penso que a roma fez contato 1 a 3
aos três após um debate profundo e
fundos perfume em espanhol vai
tranqüilizar e vou pegar nacional
ela vai ficar pesada são também com suas
sombras humilhado isso como um braço
meada e 6 como se fosse uma toalha
molhada e quando que você vai sentir
ainda não trazer nós por isso se entende
muito bem em segurança
neste momento a mãe casamento profunda
fez algo muito interessante
gostaria neste momento me texto
eles sentem paloma está sentado em
frente e para trás na frente e vemos que
você nunca perde o controlo paloma tanto
nervosa ainda não só serve só serve
fácil descontrair que vai lançando para
frente e para trás
naturalmente é somente fica leve livre
funcionamento sem corpo podendo viajar
no tempo e no espaço
nesta ópera que já não é 2016 também
pode perceber que já não está de making
meia esquerda também não está nem sequer
em 2000
neste momento você pode deixar a sua
meta o ébrio livro viajar pro mengo da
sua inverse momento especial para a nona
o momento você sente totalmente à mãe
que detém na forma açodada pessoas que
você gosta momento amargo em especial
simples lá neste momento é propósito
tempo espero realmente que se ela esta
vivência momento percebendo que uma
parte boa da paloma está muito longe no
futuro passando com a espanha sempre
óptica enquanto que a sua parte infância
está vivenciar vendo e sentindo spencer
neste momento tem fãs neste momento e
sendo apenas psicólogo encontra delta
obter a sua em profunda como assinala
quando você encontra um momento
agradável especial repetto momento
agradável especial da sua infância
façamos saber isso levantando o dedo
indicador da sua mão esquerda quando
tiver em conta o momento assinalou
conhecido por favor não vou procurar
e quando sentir que a sua cotação foi
comum em especial paloma
pra mim a ecosul dedo indicador da mão
direita no final você possa viver ao
pormenor essa experiência óptima muito
vai vai piorar ela também muito simples
coluna gostaria de comentar o tempo de
trânsito contra o colega aqui somente
profunda prometer com a servir em ver
este momento sempre escuro em duas malas
enquanto que o outro foi ao encontro é
quem gostaria que ela dissesse você está
segura em dos meus vivem dessa
experiência sabendo que eu estou aqui ao
lado para acorrer a qualquer situação
que acontecer todavia gostaria que a sua
renda profunda motorização até pergunto
colega é que o lado certo autorizar
falamos sobre isso
otto não durma e vive esse momento
estarei ao seu lado a mente inconsciente
e chama situação tem prova totalmente
consciente e presente é vivida no
momento é por questões éticas porque a
pessoa nunca perde o controlo
primeiro tenho que me segurar aquela
encontra uma experiência agradável
porque eu posso precisar mas conheci
eventualmente traumática e pode colocar
as crianças então tenho que me segurar
atravessa uma meta comunicação
movimentos reflexo autores que ela iria
encontrar uma experiência agradável do
passado
em seguida garantir a mente inconsciente
que a acusada está a viver essa
experiência eu não estiver sozinha
permitindo ao mesmo tempo trabalhar com
outro colega enquanto que ela vivencia
ou sempre aquela experiência
a partir do momento que nós cumprimos a
essas condições éticas até para é
problema não sentir abandonada digamos
no passado
a partir daí nós temos condições de
efetivar mente para é continuar com os
colegas um é brincar é mostrar as peças
com os colegas
o mais engraçado nisso tudo é que é é a
coluna continua a mover e continuar a
saber que está aqui mas neste momento é
como se não fosse importante construir
essa dizer sabe como é
nós temos
mesmo uma festa começar com o colega e
esquecemos ruídos as suas ao lado a
música tocar em nenhum momento nosso
foco é conversa com o colega tudo o
resto não é tão importante como isso é
uma técnica que nós utilizamos chamada
deep house que permita furar
recalcamentos situações mal resolvidas
do passado e que eventualmente são
trabalhadas contextualizadas na
segurança consultório com terapeuta já
que nós vamos fazer uma espécie de
resgatar a criança interior forçando a
criança perdida é criança abandonada a
criança maltratada entanto é é através
dessa técnica que nós fazem cinco
minutos em que efetivamente nós podemos
com a mente demente hipnotizada não só
recuar na adolescência a infância é a um
investimento e até a vida em outro ou
seja nós temos mora já dentro do ventre
do outro materno e isso é um dos maiores
potenciais da equipe nós experiência que
você está a viver continua a ser verdade
passamos a ter isso paloma
agora com o colega op em muito vai
conhecendo essas preze
essa é uma forma de uma meta começar a
trabalhar com a mente consciente também
a utilização controlada isso porque ela
continua numa situação legal sobre o
problema que ela sente confortável anos
aqui é nosso colega
desculpem lá ataque o avaí também é
conhecido o hino network e foi dito o
seguinte 'você vai privatizar esse cara
é o francisco não porque eu não acredito
em hipnose não canta disso networking é
exótico é bom não acreditar em nós a
pimenta que esteja capaz de colaborar
com o meio campista hipnose e eu podem
efetivamente entrar em hipnose está
disposto a colaborar comigo pra entrar
em hipnose vai disponibilizar se a fazer
aquilo que eventualmente certo de que
alguma coisa aí a otan é você tem que
dar tom de 2 32 anos deixam fazer o
esquenta e outra
uma das coisas mais espetaculares da
hipnose chama sttrans concessionária que
nós queremos enfatizar uma pessoa numa
simples conversa
elton é possível que você nunca tenha
sido regularizado antes e que esteja
muito curiosa investimento entrar em
transe agora eu gostaria que soubesse eu
estou perfeitamente dispostos a
comprometer você leva o tempo que
precisa para ter entre moscou e com do
transe hipnótico uma certeza que está em
boas mãos porque não quero quem traz
rapidamento assim deixa eu perguntar e
quando consegue 30 em terra em transe
hipnótico agora daqui a pouco um ótimo
se você não tem que puxar os olhos pra
entrar em transe
mas é importante o que realmente é
importante você prestar atenção a minha
voz e tentasse perceber que tipo de
mudanças irão acontecer à medida que
aprender a aprender em outra entrar em
transe hipnótico sem mesmo saber que já
sabia entrar em transe claro desde o
início tá pronto para entrar em transe
hipnótico agora perfume drama calma e
aprofundamento sempre atento a minha voz
eu quero que a sua mão fica
completamente pesada sabe cansada ea sua
mão aumentar de tamanho
você não se importam peças ou não ela
vai passar mesmo como se fosse uma
toalha molhada
ae isso é sinal também está muito pesada
cada vez mais pesada a sua cabeça está
cada vez mais pesada em alta e é natural
que se sinta culpa que reduzirá mesmo
talento todo o corpo a encarnar uma
porquinha total
tá querendo mais mas você vai perder
toda o tônus o corpo todo o tônus o
corpo vai ficar como se fosse uma toalha
molhada completamente molhada
chama-se hipotonia total é bom pra
provocar a nau sem piloto que poderia
agora não vou fazer tocar numa agulha de
passar de mamão um braço que não
exigiria minimamente podemos fazer uma
catalepsia uma catalepsia é os braços
até o corpo totalmente rígido
essa epidemia total
além do agradava o orçamento traz
sensações de bem-estar e da
tranquilidade está provado inclusive por
respostas químicas chave nesse estado a
um incremento destas endorfinas
estrutura menina inclusive harmonia
responsável por fazer é tamina já que
isso vai estimular os circuitos do
prazer
portanto a chave para que nós numa dois
minutos conseguimos fazer um estado
hipnótico e conseguimos criar estado
especiais da tensão que permite mudanças
primeiro controlador tenha efectivamente
estimular os níveis é o anti libertar os
níveis de ansiedade já que o facto o
corpo em alto estresse embora me tenha
acelerado
sendo assim nada que está cheia de
noradrenalina e se impede efetivamente a
pessoa de viver um momento especial no
momento entre nós como vice
além de um é vw acostamento é capaz
possíveis mudanças sensoriais e motoras
com muita facilidade
só para dizer que há a além do airton
não acreditar em hipnose é o ciclo
vicioso para computa pudesse acontecer
agora vamos ver outro fenômeno bem
interessante é tentar minha voz
concentrar na minha voz qualquer som
senhora eu também só serve para acalmar
ainda mais e mais por fundamento
eu vou ter a sua menta profunda que
permitiu criar esse maravilhoso da trans
permita cunha e outra pura e
simplesmente ganito necessidade da
cintura para cima do apito ganhe por
necessidade da cintura pra cima
os pés estão muito pesados a otan cada
vez mais pesados suas coxas tá muito
pesadas e outra ainda mais pesado
os pés suas pernas em suas coxas estão
lá os pesados
você percebe que suas peças suas pernas
com cheques fossem os pés no estado
mágoa
você sabe como é é como se não sentisse
são tão preso à cadeira
daqui a pouco abrir os olhos com mais
força que você faça um enxerto
eles não mexem com rita ambiente kolat
eu vou contar de uma 3 aos três paradas
nos olhos extratos perto da cintura pra
cima mas da cintura para baixo o socorro
continua profundamente em transe
atenção eu tenho uma tenta minha voz 23
isso é o que toda mãe natureza
assim exposto você tira o momento não
foi não
eu trato todo mundo está muito curioso
é impossível você que é um centro
relativamente à hipnose se efetivamente
é é capaz de passar por alguns final do
campeonato você gostaria de passar por
um filme plástico tô falando alguma
coisa há mudanças no seu corpo foram
acontecendo desde que estou aqui
qual é a principal diferença é que você
tem da pax mas o corpo relativamente
baixo
acha que está tudo normal deixa eu
perguntar uma coisa é normal neste
momento ea maioria das suas de 70 em
transe
além de comentar não é dado a
conhecimentos em algumas partes do corpo
causadas 16 para aumentar sua mãe como
se fosse feito de mármore
você consegue perceber isso
não quero nem me perguntar lhe se você
seria capaz neste momento de
experimentar os melhores agentes foram
os mais interessantes da mente humana ou
seja será capaz de nascimento de tentar
mexer uma palha
tem que mexer uma palha inveja
o quanto está pagando por um crime não
fosse apanhar aí eu tenho que tentar
suportar ver se consegue
certa vez consegue já tentam não está
assustado pois na minha opinião se
contentam em cena antes mais é isso é
possível porque é possível a hipótese é
total
uma pátria total e para mim é a minha
profunda para só é voltar é introduzido
torno de metade do corpo enquanto o
outro ficava totalmente o tônico
ou seja enquanto não tentou no seu
bunker ordem que dei é é um suco que não
existe porque não tem planos para reagir
portanto os tornaria o engraçado é que
eu estava esperto está perfeitamente
consciente
no entanto não controla notado o corpo
pensa nisto mesmo potencial disto em
termos de controlo da dor mas sim não o
potencial visto uma cirurgia por exemplo
imagine o potencial disso é eterna vaso
constituição ao vazio votação é nosso
facto tem uma abrangência clínica
extraordinária e nós somos capazes de
coisas surpreendentes
essa pessoa se permitir entrar em transe
hipnótico entrar em transe prótons com
isso eu tô com toda a calma
sempre vou contar com uma empresa e
outra aos 3 você vai começar a ganhar
toda cidadã em todos o corpo suas peças
começam a ganhar o ensinado nas suas
pernas suas coxas começam a ganhar
intensidade do braço soltrópico socopo
suas ondas começam a ganhar na cidade e
outra eu vou contar de 13
aos 38 nova alerta muito bem disposto
muito melhor que o saint étienne e não
vai sentir
depois dessa experiência a tensão alta 1
a disputar dois está quase esperto e tem
três portas abertas se israel
eu quero queros preguiça vamos lá mas
seus pezinhos agora exatamente por essa
cláusula e explorou na oi vai mostrar
até agora somente não precisasse
processual presente mas repetir algo
muito simples e sendo eu a outra delta
em um projetor aquilo deve estrear e
consegui essa presente com todas as
recordações de instrumento os sons as
pessoas têm alguma coisa particular
eu gostaria que você vivenciar toda essa
recordação da infância como uma espécie
de fotografia com esse processo fazendo
daqui a pouco ao episódio com sensações
que não estava médio
engana se faz sentir nas próximas horas
dias ou semanas que vai sentindo que sua
meta também a cimpor a seu favor
sua mente profunda entender que este é o
momento ideal para trazer um presente
fazendo saber isso levantando o dedo
indicador da mão esquerda tona um ótimo
muito vai fazer uma contagem de 1 a 3
paloma aos 13 e aos olhos que irá sentir
número de lançamento online calma
tranquila e melhor nesse sentido depois
pegar o presente é tendo em conta que a
paloma entrou num processo de ipo naus
ou seja é que o que vulgarmente se chama
repressão
ela podia vir em alguma circunstância é
ainda com voz da criança ou coisa do
gênero ou seja ela podia trazer a
personalidade da infância então
obviamente consciente pra fazer só a
memória das recordações as coisas boas
que ela encontrou na experiência da
forma que se tornasse efetivas é não só
agora mas que o processo tem alegria e
bem-estar porque costuma dizer nós
deixarmos ser felizes quando deixamos
não é portanto é isso que nós queremos
ouvir as populações é que devemos deixar
florescer é desabrochar a criança que
está dentro nós portanto é isso cumpre a
mente consciente e é porque mesmo que
ela não autorizou tá na altura director
geral fazendo atenção a minha voz paloma
eu vou contar de 13
aos 13 bravo nos olhos e na sentinela da
minha mãe
calma tranquila em 2000 a sentir depois
de abrir os olhos atenção um começando a
voltar aposente sentindo muito bem muito
calma 2
percebendo que as sensações das cotações
todas aquelas coisas boas você tem 10 a
fundação também consigo atenção pelo
menos 37 o diabetes e se disse muito bem
muito calmo em perfeito equilíbrio na
empresa
um aplauso paloma
assim hoje eu já acho de largamente o
tempo conflito havia muito mais a fazer
podia fazer uma insensibilidade à dor
podia fazer uma produção na acção podia
fazerem essas coisas
visto que os voluntariosos amento
colaboraram comigo mas tiveram aqui dois
cachorros 7 é paloma que achou uma certa
graça entrar no processo eo algodão que
diz eu não acredito nada descreve fui
pra avenida e exalta o eu também como
você sabe o nome porque não soube fazer
isso aconteça e eu disse que não e pinot
szabo selo foram desmontadas e
hipnotizou portanto mostrou que não
estava toda a hipnose e virar uma
funcionária que nós
outra pessoa que acreditava e que
deslizam suavemente para nós
eu costumo dizer o senhor nós não é tudo
a hipnose é o princípio de tudo saibamos
nós dar uma pintada técnica para que ela
possa mostrar todo seu potencial
muito obrigado é móvel popular mas sim o
tempo
obrigado galera